we just saw amd talking about their new
6000 series cards
a lot to be excited about if you're
anyone except nvidia they have
come out of the gates swinging what do
we what do we think about what we've
seen
well i think that like you said amd's
coming out strong
with uh their new lineup that they just
showed off um at the
we're recording this right after we just
saw the uh the reveal
and it's pretty impressive on paper is
what i'll say so they revealed three
different video cards the
6800 xt the 6800 and the 6900 xt
uh different price tiers different
performance tiers
but it really seems like uh they have an
answer to everything that
nvidia is doing even on the tech side of
things which we'll get into with
things like ray tracing amd has an
answer to that finally because we've
been waiting
for them to do something nvidia has been
pretty much
in control of the graphics processing
for pc
for pc gaming for a very long time now
so
when amd had revealed these cards and
their internal performance metrics
i think there there is a lot to be
excited about in
amongst the like pc gaming community
where there's a lot of chat about
stock price our performance ratio
i think amd also hit all of that right
on the head as well
i think that's the main concern now is
like in 2020 are they going to be able
to produce enough units to keep up with
what we've seen a big demand for new gen
cards like i think that if they can sort
that out there
this this might be amd's turn to go out
in front
yeah that is that is a really good point
in terms of uh as we saw with the rtx
3080 and the 3090 launches
uh there's those cards are very
difficult to find
um so supply has been low but demand has
been high so if amd can kind of
fit themselves into where there's still
demand and not a lot of supply from
nvidia i think they can
really start to make some moves into
pc gamers rigs which would be great but
the question of supply is some is an
unknown variable
we have no idea what their supply chain
looks like we have no no idea what will
happen
once these cards launch uh next month in
november
uh so those are unknown variables but
what we do know
is that these cards are priced
competitively uh
in relative to their nvidia counterparts
so i guess we want to start with the
6800 xt
dave what do you what do you think about
it the 6800 xt
for 50 bucks cheaper having such
competitive performances to nvidia's
3080
that's honestly i didn't really expect
the competition
it came to performance to be so close
and
now they're also saying that it's
performance
is going to be a lot more sustainable
it's
how much power it's using is for me that
was like well
sure it's 50 bucks cheaper but you're
also going to save money because chances
are that's going to be a lot of people
not having to upgrade a power supply as
well so there's
there's more than one aspects to keep in
mind when you're upgrading
to a new gpu now the all those things
you mentioned are are important uh the
one thing that i
am keeping an eye on though is those
internal benchmark numbers
i'm really curious to see what how these
cards stack up to each other in
practical scenarios is what i'll say but
uh so amd has always been the sort of
company that offers the uh offers value
uh as we've seen it in their recent past
so
uh 50 cheaper already inserts them into
the conversation
where even if they are a few frames per
second behind in benchmarks
people will still consider well it's 50
cheaper
i don't know if that's gonna play in
that big into a factor considering that
uh like things never go directly for
msrp that's just like an
a rough estimate of what board partners
put out but the fact that they are
aiming for
something that's a little bit cheaper
that is that seems to perform on par
uh and i guess better in some scenarios
i mean we'll see
i wouldn't say it's it's surprising but
uh it's it's necessary it's about time
that they're doing this
and uh we'll talk a little bit more
about the rdna ii texture with uh
architecture which is on the new uh
consoles
but we are seeing some of the things
that they've been talking about or has
microsoft has been talking about with
consoles
finally come through in the the new pc
hardware that we're getting from amd
like having all of their names attached
to
consoles as well i think it's going to
i think i think it just inserts them
into the conversation of gaming
as a whole again but
when it comes to backgrounds the pc
performance
the 6900 xt i think is the one that
everyone wants to talk about right it
was the 30 90 that everyone was excited
for because
it's the big what did we call it last
time the flex card
yeah and their flex card is a little
lighter on the wallet now
i say a little white lies are on the
wallet and
again the performance it seems to put
out against it the 30 90 and the
2080 ti pretty exciting numbers yeah
the i mean i'm personally i don't
necessarily
care about that super duper high end
stuff it gets people excited but
um i think that what what speaks to me
is
what the what our dna2 is capable of at
the top end
it kind of speaks to what i said earlier
about envy or about amd
you know shying away from this the super
high-end enthusiast level
uh in their recent past uh but now that
they have a platform like
rdna 2 to finally you know have a
strong foundation to build from i think
that's the
that's my important takeaway when they
reveal the 6900 xt
i think something that's more practical
is the 6800
the not xt version that's sort of like
the mid high range version that's going
to go for
580 bucks this one's a little tricky
because
it's situated in between the
3080 and nvidia's 30-70 which just
launched
and it is kind of wedging itself it's
trying to wedge itself
wise between those two cards to kind of
fill in that gap
the tricky part is i want to see how it
stacks against the 30-70 directly even
though it's
technically 80 dollars more expensive i
want to make sure that you know
if someone's going to go out and buy a
6800
that they are actually getting better
performance than they would have with
the 3070
and that's going to be an interesting
thing to see not only how they stack but
their availability and if you're on
nvidia's
previous platforms right now if you
should make the jump uh or if you're
waiting for that notify button to turn
into an add to cart button for your 30
70 or 3080
that you've been chomping at the bit for
like if amd can say hey
our cards are available they're also
performing
on par if not better and i suppose it's
worth talking about as well
the idea of the synergy between
their gpus and cpus and not everyone is
going to have
a ryzen cpu and and make the most out of
that
synergy it feels like it's been a while
since we've had to think about like oh
what
what gpu am i going to have to plug with
my cpu
are they going to talk properly like i i
remember having those worries
i know like seven eight years ago when i
was building pcs
and then i was like i don't have to
worry about it for a good
a good while but now right and like
that's that's obviously what the
benchmarks were right
perfect case scenario with their gpus
with their cpus
i'd be if i had a ryzen in my machine
i'd be like well i've not been able to
find
a 3080 for love nor money they're about
as rare as rocking horse dung at the
minute
my cpu is going to talk much friendlier
with the radeons so yeah that that's a
major thing too
is that they've claimed that you can get
up to a 13
boost in performance when you've paired
a ryzen 500 5000 series
cpu on a 500 i think the
500 series chipset motherboard with
a a radeon 6000 series card
i know it's a lot to kind of chew on but
it's uh the motherboard the cpu and the
gpu
when they're all working in tandem
there's uh there's different
technologies in which they like you've
said can communicate with each other for
better efficiency
which turns into better performance now
on this the stream we just saw amd
didn't go into like the technical
details of like exactly how that works
but that's an incredible case for like
uh for people to stay within brand this
also speaks to what they've been doing
in the console space
uh this is an extension of that so i'm
not too surprised to see how it's
playing out on pc
they've talked a lot about things like
variable rate shading
smart access memory sampler feedback
streaming uh
and just the ways in which that velocity
architecture
everything kind of communicates with
each other it's all one
solid ecosystem that's what we're that's
what amd is showing off
for pc gaming now it's kind of just
taking that same design philosophy but
now offering it if you pair
all those amd products together i'm
hyped for it but
obviously over the coming weeks
hopefully we're going to be running all
sort of tests benchmarks and reviews
of the radeon cards so stay tuned for
that i'm sure you'll
you'll love doing that home you'd love a
good benchmarking oh that's a lot of
work but
i'll do it that's right we're we're in
the words of high school musical
we're all in this together if you want
to see us all in this together
you can subscribe so you don't miss out
on all this lovely
pc gaming content we'll see you next
time